[Music]
shiloh jolie pitt is a bona fide dancing
queen proving she's an artist in the
making and that talent runs in the
family you know we want to make it a
family fair angelina and brad pitt's 16
year old daughter is setting the
internet on fire showing off her
impressive dance skills and it's safe to
say shiloh's got to move
in a series of videos posted by
choreographer hamilton evans shiloh
dances to the latest hit songs here she
is front and center nailing every move
to doji cats vegas
[Music]
her footwork effortless while grooving
to lizzo's about damn time feeling fussy
walking in my valencia season
and shiloh even shows off her
versatility slowing things down to
rihanna's track skin
[Music]
safe to say this young performer is
making her mark in the dance world i
imagine her parents are proud because
over the years brad and angie have been
vocal about their six kids following
their dreams i feel like my world
expands as their world expands
i learn so much from them and proving
talent runs in the family shiloh's big
brother maddox is in the family biz too
the actress opened up to e.t back in
2017 about working with her eldest on
first they killed my father a film
maddox co-produced alongside his mamas
when we did our notes in the production
meetings his were always better than
mine he's very studious
but he's got a wicked sense of humor and
he's very fun to be with so
i don't know he's kind of when your
children are your best friends it's kind
of a it's a nice life and with that kind
of support we hope it means lots more
dancing from shiloh
in a minute i'ma need a sentimental man
a woman to pump me up
you